all my tech talk is not on point i'm  asking you why so i went to reels like  what i was told going into like to the  music industry they were like use the  platform that works and go hard on that  so that's why i've been going hard on  real the fact that you're listening to  some [ __ ] mid lower tier music  executive versus me makes me want to  throw i am listening to you no you're  not i am going i'm gonna do all that i  haven't i haven't actually like started  the  tick tock four times a day here's why  i'm so high strung on this this is good  this is it's not about [ __ ] instagram  it's first of all it's always and never  or  because if you here's my thing you want  it so bad i know i know  there's a lot of people in the world  that want it there's two parts to  getting it you need to want it you need  to know what the [ __ ] to do and i'm  giving you what to do on a silver  platter and i also know this is where  the anxiety comes from it's gonna go  away